if like us your step counters have been
reduced to tracking your movement
between the fridge and the couch look no
further than these seven games
guaranteed to get you up and moving even
if you can't get out to the gym first up
this ring fit Nintendo's RPG light
workout adventure that uses a ring
peripheral includes bright visuals and
oh yeah it's sold out everywhere I want
to skip over this one quickly since
you're only really gonna be able to play
it if you already have it but this has
been my personal favorite fitness game
the RPG aspects and level designed do a
brilliant job of making working out fun
and the Nayan constant encouragement
from your trusty ring will keep you
pressing through the next set but let's
move on to some games you can definitely
get your hands on ring fit isn't the
only offering on Nintendo's switch you
can also pick up fitness boxing
fortunately no peripherals are required
so you can get digital downloading now
if it sounds like your thing Fitness
boxing is a rhythm game where you'll
punch and dodge along to the beat of
modern pop songs your exercise
repertoire expands the more you play
you'll be constantly reminded about
proper form and it's a hell of a cardio
workout you can also tailor your routine
to focus on different muscle groups if
you want a deeper dive into fitness
boxing you can check out the video I
made after playing it for 10 days
fitness boxing also has a free three day
trial on switch so check that out if you
think it might be keen if Connie our
boxing sounds a bit intense you can just
dance if you don't mind the idea of
buggying down just dance continues to
iterate with the biggest top 40 tracks
and the moves to go along with them for
a few extra bucks the just dance
unlimited package also lets you choose
from a library of over 500 songs
including those from previous games and
new exclusives so it's well worth it if
you're getting tired of a few dozen that
come packed in with any one game the
massive upside to just dance is that
it's available on just about any
platform you'd want it on and you can
use motion controllers or just your own
smartphone that syncs up with the Just
Dance app if however boxing is totally
your thing but you'd prefer to be a
little more immersed this box VR box VR
is also a cardio boxing game but you'll
be throwing on a VR headset for this one
the game is updated regularly with new
workouts designed by actual professional
fitness instructor
and there's a workout generator that you
can use to create workouts based on your
own music depending on your headset you
may encounter some not so fun sweat
issues but rest assured you will be
working one up for a less traditional
workout game you shouldn't pass up one
of Eos best offerings beats a bow
essentially you rhythmically fend off
colored blocks with lightsabers at
increasing speeds and complexity there's
a no-fail mode if you prefer but
smashing through difficult levels is far
more satisfying especially if you start
using modifiers that make songs trickier
if that isn't enough beat Sabre recently
released fit beat it's a free fitness
track with standard 90-degree and 360
degree levels and it's an even bigger
challenge than the standard tracks so
check it out if you do a cardio day if
you feel like your workouts have been
missing a generous helping of making you
feel like John wick check out the VR
game a pistol whip pistol whip has you
moving constantly on Rails but you'll
need to aim dodge and maneuver yourself
physically to take out enemies that pop
up through each level as in the other
cases hotter difficulties will get you a
better workout but the nature of the via
action shooter makes it a hell valla or
appealing than hitting the gym the
bright eye catching visuals and bass
heavy tracks suddenly don't hurt either
for potentially the most strenuous
workout on this list depending on how
you play you may want to check out
sprint vector it's another VR title but
she'll be swinging your arms using
motion controls to move forward through
the game's fast-paced courses and
applying some skill and strategy to
navigate the best way through on top of
that it's a competitive multiplayer game
so if you need a little fire under you
to get your best workout this could be
the way to go
the electric music is pumping the levels
are a visual delight and while the
controls can take some getting used to
this one will definitely get your heart
rate up let me know if you've tried any
of these out in the comment box or which
fitness games appeal to you and I'll
catch you next time
[Music]
you